AND WIDE
OFF THE SKATE.
GOOD RETRIEVALSSES.
DRAWS MERRILL TO HIM AND OPENS
ACROSS TO MAKE  THE MOMENTUM OF
PLAY FOR THE SECOND TIME.
WE E ES THAT BETWEEN
HIS RIGHT ARM AND BODY.
>> DID KAHKONEN GET A PIECE OF
THAT SHOT? WAS CONNOR.
HE'LL SEND IT IN.
WHEELER POURS IN AFTER IT.
GLOVE OPEN.
AND A SECOND HALF RESET IS
REQUIRED.
WHILE THE ZUCCARELLO BACK
TO HIS OWN END.
ITIT
GAME.
SAW THAT ON THAT ONE ON ONE
MERRILL, SENDS IT OFF FOR
KULIKOV.
JETS CONSECUTIVELY FROM
TAKES IT
AND CLEAR
BUT NOW YOU HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
FIRST 20 MINUTES AGAINST A
REALLY GOOD TEAM AND YOUNATE SM
PUTS IT BACKFORE-CHECK. IN.
AND WILL CITIZEN IT OFF FOR
FOLIGNO.
10 GOALS IN HIS LAST 23E CALLEDY
WILL GET STOPPED.
>> THIS THI OF THE NET.LINE.
HE WILL GO FOR
COLORADO AND HE WILL PUT THIS
CLOSE TO IT DEFENSIVELY AND
THAT'S BEEN THE CAS WILL SLIP I
AND GO HERE IN
THE THIRD PERIOD.
TRYING TO WORK IT AWAY FROM
CONNOR.  TO THE LINE
CHOPPED AWAY.
AFTE DAM LOWRY.
KULIKOV.
BACK TO THE WHEELER MISSED
IT.
HE HAS GEOMETRY,REASON IT'S ONLY
HAVE HAD A  A DEMELO DISH TO 26
NUMBER 25 BY THE SECOND
THETY-NET GOAL T
71-30-8 AS THE WILD HEAD COACH.
>> THEY'RE